[Música]
bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días el magazine
informativo de france 24 dedicado al
continente africano en esta edición
iremos a argelia donde el presidente
venezolano nicolás maduro se reunió con
su homólogo abdel mediante boom para
reforzar los lazos económicos políticos
y culturales entre ambos países
seguiremos en mali los militares que
gobiernan el país fijaron un plazo de
dos años para llevar a cabo la
transición democrática
el coronel así migoya firmó un decreto
para un retorno al gobierno civil en
marzo de
2024 esta decisión pretende suavizar las
relaciones con la comunidad económica de
estados de áfrica occidental que ha
impuesto fuertes sanciones al país e
iremos también a marc huecos donde el
festival de música gnawa regresó
finalmente tras dos años de ausencia
debido a la pandemia de kobe 19
abrimos esta edición en argelia donde el
presidente de venezuela nicolás maduro
aterrizó el pasado miércoles 8 de junio
en el marco de una gira internacional
que lo ha llevado a pasar por turquía e
irán el viaje de maduro a argelia
coincidió con la cumbre de las américas
en eeuu a la que washington excluyó al
presidente venezolano
en argel la capital argelina maduro
mantuvo conversaciones con su homólogo
abdelmajid tep un tanto argelia como
venezuela son miembros de la
organización de países exportadores de
petróleo y comparten además otros
vínculos históricos para renovarlos los
mandatarios acordaron la creación de una
comisión para elaborar una hoja de ruta
económica energética comercial y
cultural entre ambas naciones
escuchemos a los líderes
hemos decidido construir una poderosa
agenda económica comercial financiera de
trabajo conjunto de prosperidad común
entre los dos países
en cuanto a nuestras relaciones
bilaterales
hemos acordado reforzar las asociaciones
económicas y culturales
y si dios quiere abrir una línea aérea
directa entre caracas y argel en dos
meses
maduro también respaldó a argelia en su
postura sobre la autodeterminación del
sáhara occidental' históricamente
confrontada a la de marruecos que
reclama su soberanía sobre el territorio
precisamente en esta cuestión las
tensiones entre argel y madrid no
disminuyen la crisis entre los dos
países estalló después de que el
gobierno de pedro sánchez reconociera la
soberanía marroquí sobre el sáhara
occidental' recordemos que este
territorio es una antigua colonia
española
incluida en la lista de la onu de
regiones pendientes de descolonización y
que argelia es el principal aliado del
frente polisario uno de los movimientos
independentistas saharauis
en respuesta al apoyo de españa a
marruecos el miércoles 8 de junio
argel suspendió un tratado de amistad
con madrid y anunció restricciones
comerciales
escuchemos la reacción del gobierno
español
estamos en estos momentos
analizando
exactamente las implicaciones de esa
medida el alcance práctico las
implicaciones tanto a nivel nacional
como también a nivel europeo para
dar la respuesta adecuada a serena
constructiva pero también firme en la
defensa de los intereses de españa y de
los intereses de las empresas españolas
lo lamento pero no me disculpo así se
podría resumir la postura del rey felipe
de bélgica en su primera visita oficial
a la república democrática del congo
para reforzar los lazos entre bruselas y
su ex colonia el miércoles 8 de junio el
monarca pronunció un discurso sobre los
crímenes cometidos por su país durante
el período colonial sin embargo los
congoleños deseaban que el rey fuera más
allá que hace dos años cuando expresó su
arrepentimiento
una carta al presidente de la rdc félix
dice que esta vez muchos esperaban una
disculpa tal vez incluso una reparación
económica pero el monarca no fue tan
lejos escuchemos
con motivo de mi primer viaje al congo
aquí delante del pueblo congoleño y de
los que aún hoy lo sufren quiero
reafirmar mi más profundo pesar y
arrepentimiento por las heridas del
pasado
en noticias de malí las autoridades
militares en el gobierno fijaron un
plazo de dos años para acceder el poder
a la sociedad civil la promesa pretende
apaciguar las relaciones con la
comunidad económica de estados de áfrica
occidental la cedeao que impuso fuertes
sanciones a damasco a principios de
enero
en marzo de 2024 esta es la fecha
anunciada por la junta militar maliense
para entregar el poder a los civiles
la duración de la transición en mali
está fijada en 24 meses a partir del 26
de marzo de 2022 y el anuncio se produjo
dos días después de una cumbre de la
comunidad económica de estados de áfrica
occidental cedeao el 9 de enero la
autoridad regional había impuesto
medidas de represalia comercial y
financiera a mali como el cierre de su
espacio aéreo a sus vecinos y la
suspensión del comercio de bienes no
esenciales
el objetivo era obligar a la junta a
presentar un calendario de transición
rápida por su parte durante su última
cumbre la cedeao había confirmado el
avance de las negociaciones con la junta
maliense ofreciendo así algo de
esperanza de futuro
de inmediato tú finalize la cedeao pidió
al mediador que finalizará la
negociación la discusión con las
autoridades malienses que permitirá la
eliminación gradual de las sanciones las
sanciones económicas y financieras que
se impusieron
desde 2012 malí está sumido en una
profunda crisis de seguridad política y
humanitaria los coroneles que tomaron el
control del país por la fuerza en agosto
de 2020 habían prometido organizar
elecciones el pasado febrero pero
renegaron de esta decisión e incluso
planearon gobernar hasta cinco años más
después de que las sanciones de la
cedeao acentuarán la crisis económica en
el país los militares redujeron sus
pretensiones a 24 meses decisión que
finalmente han hecho oficial en áfrica
las relaciones entre personas del mismo
sexo todavía son ilegales en 37 países
sin embargo en ruanda no es así pero
esto no impide que las identidades
diversas sean frecuentemente excluidas y
estigmatizadas
en comparación con muchas naciones
africanas donde pertenecer a la
comunidad lgbt
más es ilegal ruanda parece ser un
refugio seguro ahmed tiene 29 años y yo
de uganda tras ser torturado por su
sexualidad por miembros de las fuerzas
de seguridad su cuerpo aún lleva las
marcas de lo que tuvo que soportar y me
golpearon terriblemente me golpearon
terriblemente y centerbridge hoy
mientras espera su nuevo destino el
joven se recupera de sus heridas su caso
ha sido tratado por el alto comisionado
de las naciones unidas para los
refugiados
cuando llegue a ruanda funcionario de
acnur me aconsejó que no revelara mi
sexualidad a nadie por miedo a que me
causará problemas sin embargo me aclaro
que aquí no es un delito ser miembro de
la comunidad lgtb más es londres crime y
juliana derecha
en abril de este año el gobierno del
reino unido anunció un polémico plan
para enviar a sus solicitantes de asilo
a ruanda kigali se prepara para acoger a
miles de refugiados algunos de los
cuales son el eje más manifestar su
orientación sexual no es ilegal sin
embargo sigue siendo estigmatizante y no
puedo ir a ningún sitio ni solicitar un
trabajo no porque no pueda sino por lo
que soy ese es el problema
el 17 de mayo los miembros de las
comunidades lgbt más de todo el mundo
celebraron el día internacional contra
la homofobia la bifobia y la transfobia
el desfile de isa no apoyado por la
unión europea tuvo lugar en kigali y
contó con modelos de la comunidad pero
aun que ruanda está por delante de otras
naciones del continente para muchos el
país todavía tiene un largo camino que
recorrer
vamos ahora a marruecos donde el
festival de música con agua tendrá lugar
en varias ciudades del país el evento
comenzó la semana pasada en la mítica
ciudad de esauira informe de yoma gílmer
esa huída la ciudad del viento protegida
por sus suntuosas murallas del siglo 18
mogador como se la conoce aquí y su
legendaria playa una de las más bellas
de marruecos vuelve por fin con sus
visitantes y su tradicional festival de
música tras dos años de interrupción por
la pandemia el festival de nagua celebra
su aniversario 25 y comienza con el
ineludible desfile de lana wii en el
corazón de la ciudad del isr
este año y por primera vez la gira del
festival será itinerante y tendrá lugar
en cuatro ciudades del reino
nos hemos visto obligados un poco por
razones de salud a aplazar el festival
esta vez será un programa diferente por
supuesto cada ciudad tendrá su propio
programa con sus funciones musicales y
sus conciertos en agua
ss fricción es agradable
[Música]
y estas fusiones que han dado fama al
festival ya han hecho las delicias de
los espectadores son y serán más
fascinantes que las precedentes
[Música]
realmente vi a todo el mundo moverse
sientes que la vida vuelve eso es de
hecho la vida vuelve porque la música en
la vida
[Música]
la noche cae sobre la ciudad de mogador
y los conciertos se suceden con
encuentros improbables y artistas
comprometidos
[Música]
estoy aquí para defender a las mujeres
en general es parte de mi carrera es
parte de mi objetivo es parte de mi
trabajo apoyar a las mujeres y a los
niños
[Música]
marrakech también será una de las
paradas de la gira del festival en agua
así como casablanca y rabat la capital
de marruecos
[Música]
le suena el nombre de abraham pétrovich
aníbal seguramente no pero pétrovich fue
un esclavo probablemente procedente de
la región de chad que vivió durante el
siglo 18 en este cuadro lo vemos de niño
al servicio de un paternalista char
pedro el grande el joven esclavo
ascendió en la escala militar hasta
alcanzar el rango de general su hijo
mayor ivan fundó la ciudad de gerson
ubicada actualmente en ucrania y uno de
sus hijos menores fue el abuelo del
famoso poeta alexander pushkin hoy es
una de las muchas figuras
afrodescendientes evocadas por colores
sant jordi en su cuenta instagram la
artista británica de 24 años inició este
proyecto para recordar que la vida de
las personas afrodescendientes no se
limitaba a la servidumbre de las
plantaciones a pesar del racismo y los
abusos algunos consiguieron abrirse paso
en la alta sociedad de los siglos 18 y
les dejamos con las imágenes de esta
cuenta de instagram gracias a los
equipos de producción gracias a nuestra
editora lorena pérez y gracias a ustedes
por acompañarnos
[Música]